the formula for the area of a triangle
is a is equal to one-half B times H
where a is equal to area B is equal to
length of the base and H is equal to the
length of the height so area is equal to
1/2 times the length of the base times
the length of the height solve this
formula for the height so just to
visualize this a little bit let me draw
a triangle here let me draw a triangle
just so we know what it B and H are B
would be the length of the base so this
distance right over here is B and then
this distance right here this distance
right here is our height that is the
height of the triangle you did a
lowercase H because that's how we wrote
it in the formula now they want us to
solve this formula for the height so the
formula is area is equal to 1/2 base
times height and we want to solve for H
we essentially want to isolate the H on
one side of the equation it's already on
the right hand side so let's get rid of
everything else on the right hand side
so we could do it well I'll do it one
step at a time we could kind of skip
steps if we wanted to but let's see if
we can get rid of this one half so the
best way to get rid of a 1/2 and it's
being multiplied by H is if we multiply
both sides of the equation by its
reciprocal if we multiply both sides of
equation by two over one or by two so
let's do that so let's multiply remember
anything you do to one hit one side of
the equation you also have to do to the
other side of the equation now what did
this do well the whole point behind
multiplying by 2 is 2 times 1/2 is 1 so
on the right hand side of the equation
we're just going to have a be H and on
the left hand side of the equation we
have a 2 a 2 a and we're almost there we
have a be multiplying by an H if we want
to just isolate the H we could divide
both sides of this equation by B we're
just dividing both sides you can almost
view B as the coefficient on the H we're
just dividing both sides by B and then
what do we get well the right hand side
the B's cancel out on the left hand side
we're just left with 2a over B so we get
H and I'm just swapping the sides here H
is equal to 2a over B 2 a over B and
we're done we have
solved we have solved this formula for
the height and I guess this could be
useful if someone just gave you a bunch
of areas and a bunch of base lengths and
they said keep giving me the height for
those values for those triangles